let me pull up this story we got from
timcast.com
almost 400 gallons of gas stolen from
north carolina gas station this is but
one specific moment but it's part of a
series of stories that i've been seeing
throughout the past week or so where
people are showing up and stealing gas
one of the craziest was that a van pulls
up to a gas pump and they have the
intake
on the ground and the vent had a trap
door pulls up to the pump while they're
pumping gas they open the trap door and
hook into the gas station's reservoir to
steal gas
because gas prices are so high now
there's a meme
i think you know whether whether you
find it in good or bad taste it's a see
it's from when kyle retton house was
crying in court
but now it's him at a gas station crying
holding up a gas pump
crying about the price of gas and you
know why i like the meme because it's
people who don't like kyle rettenhaus
making fun of joe biden and what's
happening with gas in this country and
all that stuff so i i highlight this
story just to show
the the uh level of strain that we're
currently experiencing for a variety of
reasons when it comes to energy and i
want to give a reminder to everybody
that when these climate change activists
say they want to end fossil fuels that
pain you're feeling at the pump where
you're joking about how you're crying as
you spend a hundred dollars to fill your
car up it's going to be 200 300 to fill
your car up when the climate change
activists get their way now i'm not
saying i'm not i'm not passing moral
judgment on climate change activism i'm
saying if you want fossil fuels to be
done with
that's fine but don't complain about you
know 300 bucks to fill up your gas tank
or are you not driving anymore
well look you want
you want you have to have fossil fuels
for our for our military and for that
it's national security
a good energy supply and you all may not
know this but texas is number one wind
energy state in the country we're number
two in solar panels right and we produce
a lot of the nation's fuel oil and gas
and i didn't say this earlier but the
keystone pipeline comes into my district
it moves 830 000 barrels of crude a day
remember when the colonial pipeline
system got hacked into last year i don't
know april or it was a disaster
southeast the southeast proteomic states
that pipeline system moves a little less
than three million barrels of product a
day
so when the colonial pipeline system is
830 000 barrels it's all it's over one
fourth
of the output
of the colonial pipeline system coming
into texas so that we can refine it we
can sell oil gasoline produce jobs
whether it's jet fuel whatever it might
be
the biden people shut that down on day
one
we wouldn't be in such a bad straight
with ukraine if the fossil fuel people
hadn't been doing such a number on i
mean the anti-fossil fuels right they
hate it it may just be me but can you
can you power a jet fighter plane with a
solar panel i don't think so well let's
talk about that uh that disaster that
happened when uh texas froze over
absolutely and uh we had we had the
mainstream media saying oh the freeze
did not affect wind energy they're lying
we had people on the right saying well
the wind turbines were struggling to
work in the cold so so can you tell us a
bit about how that how that disaster
happened absolutely you hear the term
ercot electric reliability council of
texas there's nine electric grids in the
united states texas has its own did i
mention in texas things were bigger and
better
but
85 percent of the state is is under
urcot the other 50 which a lot of us in
my district by the way entergy which
does a energy company which does a great
job
so what again growing up 20 mile radius
68 years i've never seen it be 18
degrees on galveston in galveston so
there was a lot of fossil fuel plants
natural gas we have a lot of natural gas
that were shut down normally in the
wintertime for maintenance right because
your
our biggest supply for need for
electricity is in the summer summers in
texas are hot you know what i mean
and so they shut down from maintenance
it was so cold that a lot of those
plants who weren't set up for frozen
pipes because it didn't get that cold
some of their water system froze and
then they couldn't keep pumping even the
ones that weren't down for maintenance
windmills did break
and here's a little bit of the technical
part ercot has to manage the electricity
on the grid it goes by hertz cycles 60
hertz cycles and i don't remember the
exact number but if after all of this
power consumption is being done
if it starts dropping down to 59 point
something or whatever it is
if it gets to a certain degree then
it'll backfeed and it'll burn the
windings in the generators in the
systems that are online wow and so
they've got to shut down neighborhoods
and power grids without warning because
they're watching it in real time they go
okay we're 10 minutes away you can't
email and you can't send out letters you
can't knock on doors you can't phone
call people
that's what happened to us uh last year
one of the things that would help with
that would be well let me back up
nuclear power the left hates nuclear
power if we had for no reason for no
reason you want to talk about green you
want to talk about green energy
it's it's it's zero carbon emission
energy it's safe right
it's it's it's remarkable how people
watch hollywood films and now they're
like i don't want clean reliable energy
it's remarkable but tim i saw the
three-eyed cartoon fish on the simpsons
that's right oh yeah
that's a big help right you know and and
the soviets were doing an experiment
which caused an explosion so now none of
us ever can have clean reliable energy
when i was in the texas legislature i
had south texas nuclear project in my
district over matagorda county i took my
staff in there in 2010 and we watched
them with their own eyes change out
spent fuel rods it was fascinating they
do it cleanly they do it safely they're
back up and running unit one and unit
two and they're recycling the rods uh
well they don't do it like in full
disclosure we don't do as good a job as
france does and but we can learn that
and think about how crazy it is we had
yucca mountain set aside and i've been
to nuclear waste facility in andrews
texas um
and i was waste control especially and
they have a fantastic concrete all the
state of our stuff to put in low-level
radiation waste
and so we've got yucca mountain which
was designed to do that where you can
take it away from almost every town
every city in a facility that was going
to be run by the federal government
where it would be safe and so the libs
didn't want that the democrats didn't
want that they fought against it and so
what do we do
they store that in now they store spent
nuclear waste right on site in all the
neighborhoods oh that's so fast well let
me let me i'll make a few quick points
the importance of nuclear power so one
of the challenges is that it's not
always windy
wind power sometimes can can reduce
production gets reduced often i i will
see wind turbines not even spinning
that's right when it comes to solar at
night i have an issue i'm thinking the
wind the sun goes down at night that's
right it does sure so a lot of these
renewable energies are intermittent in
terms of the generation right so
fossil fuels is reliable but so is
nuclear power
and nuclear power it's fascinating
because zero carbon emissions but for
some reason they reject it it makes me
wonder if what you were saying before
they want you dependent upon them so
they can stay in power they always want
there to be a problem only they can fix
right correct if you're watching the
geopolitical thing going back to russia
on youtube right now they've had a a a
a
misinformation program going on against
fossil fuel you know the left has had it
for a long time funneled by running a
russian money
and the the statistics are that russia
has increased their nuclear uh fleet by
30 percent
and germany has cut theirs by 80 percent
and now europe is going to be dependent
on russia and they've planned that all
along and their russian disinformation
program is trying to knock out our
fossil fuels there's a lot of ngos over
here an anti-fracking anti-pipeline uh
anti-shell exploration
that you know uh ngos or you call it
what you want to qualify with 5013c
i can do this
and they've got money we've it's been
tracked it's been documented i do i do
have that story we'll pull it up in a
second though but uh just just exploring
you know a little bit of energy as it
pertains to texas
the uh i'm confused as to what the
complaint really was from uh from the
left as to what texas did wrong it just
seemed like the only real issue they had
was exploit the crisis and claim it you
know we have the solutions to it when in
reality it seems like a freak accident
let me tell you what i heard right off
the bat i as as again i've got the most
energy probably the most energy dominant
sector now there's production over in
west texas where they drill and they
produce they send it down to pipelines
but we're reports and refineries and we
export a lot of it
people call me and said randy this is
why you know ercot shouldn't be allowed
to control the texas grid it ought to be
the federal government you know
and i said are you kidding me
i said we've got a state agency called
urcot and a lot of them live here and
they
they shop their kids go to school and do
all this stuff here and you want some
washington bureaucrat this was out of
their control we've never had this cold
winter it's never had this is a perfect
storm
and the state agency i mean it was tough
for them and the legislatures when they
met they went in and they did the things
to harden that grid so to speak
you want to give it to some bureaucrat
in washington d.c
no thank you yeah absolutely not i'll
remind you that randy is the leading
minority he's the um republican
republican ranking member on energy
subcommittee for science and technology
so when the republicans win in november
you're going to be there i will be i'll
be the chairman of the energy
subcommittee i just want to throw
i want to throw this in there i'm glad
you brought russia up because i find it
really hilarious how all of the
people who are against nuclear power and
want to demonize it are also really
comfortable with the idea of going to
war with a nation that is armed with
nukes
so we're talking about what's going to
be more likely to result in nuclear
annihilation it's frustrating oh just
give me the answer straight you know if
someone so here here's what i'm saying
before if someone comes to me and they
say you know i don't like fossil fuels
carbon emissions are bad i'll say okay
but gas is going to be extremely
expensive for the average person the
average person won't be able to commute
then they start saying oh that's not
true and they just lie they lie i had
somebody on facebook saying you know i
have no problem paying five dollars a
gallon for gas because i have a clean
conscience and ukraine is the suffering
and then i talk about how biden is
causing this and they just lie no he's
not biden actually has no no ability to
change the prices and unlike he ended
these oil and gas leases over climate
change uh lawsuits he's shut down
keystone which is is going to affect
supply and demand he's absolutely had an
impact on these things strategic oil
reserves he has a lot of power to change
these things he's absolutely responsible
not for literally everything but as our
leader and his actions yes but people
lie they lie that's what i can't say
they also don't know how how dirty it is
to actually produce the green energy
they they have no idea how much like how
these rechargeable batteries and things
like that they they sit there and well
well here's whatever happens someone
someone posted uh there's a meme going
around it's been on twitter and facebook
and it says the cost to produce wind
energy has gone up zero dollars in zero
cents since the war in russia and
ukraine i said that's not true the cost
of petrol lubricants for these have gone
up you're lying stop lying to me just
tell me the truth i can't take it so not
only that tim but think about this and
our reports did i mention we've got
seven imports more than the other member
of congress
and by the way we have strategic
petroleum reserves about 60 percent of
the nations and and why why is that
called strategic petroleum reserves it's
in our district because it's strategic
you want to keep that oil there until
you need it for a strategic reason don't
just release it so you want to try to
get out underneath the owning the fact
that you've increased the price of fuel
but
um
i was gonna i will say releasing it
didn't even do anything to drive down
prices anyway right well yes we use like
what 20 million a day windmills come
through our ports and guess what they
come on the back of when they get moved
from the port and to the
18 wheelers and guess what
and guess what 18 wheelers burn oh i
know diesel i have no problem saying
that uh wind turbines are fantastic in
my opinion you said taxes texas number
one winner it's awesome it's awesome but
just stop lying to me about everything
wind is not an end-all bl solution we
need when it comes to solar and wind we
need massive battery
industrial-sized battery systems for
storage rare earth minerals where are we
going to get those you know well alaska
yeah well alaska does africa some but
right now china a lot of the components
are from our oh i don't know our friends
in china oh yeah yeah
and rare earths actually aren't
necessarily rare we just need to start
being self-sufficient in the united
states how about making it easier to
drill easier to dig permits to mine how
about the federal government move out of
the way and let entrepreneurs and
companies do their job you know i feel
like it's because
for a lot of these democrats they need
to make sure there's a problem that they
can only be the ones to solve and we're
heavily subsidizing the green energy um
industry in general where we they were
supposed to like not have their
subsidies renewed and yet they came back
to us a second time and asked to have
them renewed and so we're paying for
that if it if it is sustainable and it
is what the
what society demands and what the market
demands then we shouldn't have to be
subsidizing them thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there